just getting here I've been on guitar  time for a week lose Crest red white and  blue got pulled chick on Chelsea Kenny  on Juventus big things from them big  sorry just getting ready I heard guitar  is beautiful this time of year  come on ref Ryan Reynolds could really  turn this team Around Jesus and a  Christian on our team hashtag blessed I  got no beer left no mean zero and soccer  ah it's getting so crowded I was a fan  before Ted lasso made soccer cool  sir sir I can't watch any more flopping  we were robbed in 18. we had to play  Trinidad and Tobago he's wide open we  need to call a timeout playing whales  what's their mascot a humpback I believe  that we will win I believe that we will  offsides is when you are behind the  other player and the  hey Siri I mean we've got England in our  group when was the last time they did  anything impressive oh you're a final  yeah was that like a play  I love this kind  of the year I can feel it but just in  case